all right hello everybody I'm sitting
here well not here but I am speaking
with Greg Hurwitz Greg Greg is a writer
professional writer he writes thriller
novels he's also written comic books and
he's written I think for movies and he's
written screenplays um we met a little
bit true
Jordan Peterson when I first met Jordan
he would always tell me these stories
about Greg and you know and they're
interacting together and kind of their
crazy stories when they were at Harvard
and and and after that so you know I'm
really happy to get to meet him and to
get to talk with him I read some of his
Batman comics and his next the first
novel that he wrote and I'm really
looking forward to exploring some of the
structures that he's able to put in
there because I can see that he's using
some symbolic structures and I think
it'd be really interesting to see how
he's able to join these structures with
particulars of his story
Wow and Greg has also been hired
recently by some high players in the
Democratic Party of the United States to
write and to put together a new ad which
is trying to let's say effect the
message that the Democratic Party is
giving and maybe even affect the party
itself and so we'll also be talking
about that so just so you know as you
see I'm not in my usual surroundings I
am in South Carolina and I'm working on
a project here with with some friends
and I'm doing some talks and everything
so so don't be surprised that this is
not my usual setting
[Music]
this is Jonathan Petro
welcome to the symbolic world
[Music]
[Applause]
maybe you can also give your own
introduction to yourself maybe tell us a
bit about what you've written about your
experience as a writer and then we'll
jump into to the storytelling
great well you covered it pretty well I
mean I write novels on my new series is
called orphan acts I've done movies and
and TV and then it worked a lot in
comics I did my first comic was The
Punisher who's my favorite character for
Marvel
I did some Wolverine I did some Moon
Knight and then I went over to DC and
wrote Batman for a couple years which
was like the most possible fun you can
have comics is like that rich kid who
lives up the street from you as all the
best toys play with all those toys and
the only slight correction I'll make to
your to your introduction is I wasn't
actually hired by the party itself to
work on this refocusing of what the
values are it was more something that we
built outside the party okay and then
figured out how to get the sort of
outside resources to show what we were
thinking about as a way to express the
Express then-prime the first principles
of the party and then we got buy-in from
the party a little bit later and a lot
of that drive for me feeling like as
Democrats that it's not so much that the
we the President Trump won the election
I feel like we lost this I feel like we
didn't do a good job at all of
articulating or fundamental values and
standing for the things that didn't
matter the most of the most people and
getting them effectively conveyed and so
what my approach was was to take a
different focus with the team of
compatriots including Callie Khouri who
wrote on Louise and Marshall herskowitz
who created 30-something and wrote the
Jack Reacher movies and created my
so-called life
we have sensibilities much more outside
of Hollywood for the most part you know
they calamy grew up in Kentucky
she wrote Nashville Marshall ran that
with her most of my books are big
thrillers I tore in the red states a lot
and so we wanted to do something that
did came from the outside and reexpress
where we thought the party should be
all right yeah so okay so maybe we could
start with that I'd be happy to make us
since we've already started on that
subject what I'm gonna do is I'm going
to play for you this four-minute ad
which you can find on youtube
I'm going to play the ad and then I'm
going to we're going to talk about it
and see if we can kind of proceed what
it is that that you're trying to do we
stand for the working men and women
always have and always will
and we define ourselves by what we've
done to help them get their shot at the
American dream Social Security the GI
Bill the Civil Rights Act Medicare
saving an auto industry 23 million
people with health insurance for the
first time in their lives and all along
it was American workers farmers and
factory workers immigrants and engineers
of every color speaking every language
who are building the highest standard of
living the world had ever seen
whose innovations were changing history
whose courage made America a beacon of
hope and freedom for those living in
tyranny around the world working people
made America work then something
happened some people in Washington took
the side of the powerful against
American workers the game got fixed for
an entire generation income flatlined
big donors made sure lawmakers cared
more about Wall Street than your street
back in the 80s a CEO made 30 times what
his workers made now they make 300 times
since the Great Recession almost all of
the income gains have gone to the top
point o 1% not 1% point of 1% instead of
raising your salary they buy back stock
to increase their own bonuses they merge
companies and reduce competition so they
can make even more money all while your
cable bill gets bigger your cell phone
bill gets higher your internet gets
slower the seat on your flight gets
smaller their taxes get lower and your
health bills get raised who's looking
out for you the people in power are so
busy giving tax breaks to the wealthiest
that they blow up the deficit and leave
nothing for roads and bridges nothing
for veterans or Medicare nothing for job
training something has to change
and we're going to change it a new
generation of leaders who know what
needs to be done and who have the will
to stand up to those who would hold us
back
we want our America back the land of
decency and fairness of generous hearts
and big dreams and the freedom for
anyone who wants to work hard to make
those dreams come true I don't care what
your politics are I don't care what God
you pray to or what color your skin is I
don't care if you ride a tractor running
business and I hope your business is a
big success as long as everybody plays
by the same rules the same rules the
same rules because this is America this
is America this is America and this is
our generations great calling to rise to
the challenge like those who had the
courage before us to build a future for
all Americans not just the few to fight
for the higher pay working people have
more than earned to fight to make health
care available to everyone who needs it
to stop those who would try to cut the
Social Security and Medicare benefits
that are rightfully yours to protect the
environment instead of selling it to the
highest bidder to fight for a government
free of corruption where your
representatives work only for you to
build a future that is just and free
full of hope and opportunity our future
our children thank us for leaving
because democracy is built not bought by
the strong and the free
[Music]
all right so one of the things that as I
watch the ad a few times and I tried to
see it one of the basic things that I
notice in the ad which I found
interesting is that you really use
you're using a u-shaped story and it's
contrast a little bit with the just the
kind of general you know this general
kind of progressive idea it seems like
you're acknowledging some of the
strengths of the past something you know
the the people and the you know the
moves that have been made in the United
States to make the the best of the
United States that brought us to where
we are today and then you kind of show
this dip where through certain political
actions certain things happened and the
things started to go awry and then
finally you offer this new solution this
new coming together and so there's this
really of this kind of u-shaped story
which we find you know in the Christian
story but you find in all kinds of
stories where you know this dissent and
inner Jordan always talks about this
story about the descendant into Hades
and then this this coming out of the
hades so maybe you can maybe tell us a
bit about how you structure the the
content in that ad well you're you're
precisely right I mean it's that's the
aspect word you know the epic of
gilgamesh adheres to the exact same
structure as the terminator
you know it's a three-act structure
that's what we use in screenplays I mean
I also just do want to acknowledge my
partner in crime mortal Hershkovitz
who's very heavily involved in the
writing and editing and production of
this too so I don't want to make it
sound like this was a solo venture so
yeah that is basically the structures us
one thing that the Democrats have not
done because it's more of a conservative
trade to honor history right and it's
one thing that we thought was really
important is to acknowledge the
strengths that the parties had in the
past and then to talk about things going
awry and also to sort of subtly you know
we don't name Republicans or Democrats
in the whole commercial like that the
words are never spoken and so things got
off course and that was that was overall
that's money in politics and corruption
and other problems and then when we
emerge from the other end it's a very
different message
want to do an ad that it really is
starting to talk about politics and
about the party in ways that people
don't usually talk about so the
structure that you've painted is
precisely the structure that we wrote
but there's things in there that we feel
like you've gotten lost in the
polarizing aspect like if discourse gets
polarized then what happens is both
sides and trench and defend the further
extremes of their parties and we wanted
to go hang on a minute we have to
celebrate merit and we have to celebrate
excellence and accomplishment and it's
not that Democrats haven't done that in
the past it's that the messaging has
ceased to do that and so when people say
you know it's a rigged game it's a
rigged game it's a game we want you know
income you want to end income inequality
well what's the reverse of that the
worst of that is income equality and for
people who are working in Congress
making a hundred and seventy five
thousand dollars a year with the world's
best health care I'm like that's not
what they want for themselves and their
kids and so I think it's much more
important to talk about for instance
income and justice meaning let's figure
out how to get the fare rules that are
the same for everybody at the starting
gate but if you're an innovator and if
you're an entrepreneur if you work
harder good on you go start a second
business or open a charity or buy
another car I mean there has to be a
celebration of accomplishment also and
so there's a lot of subtle shifts that
we we thought that were ways to focus
and refocus the messaging of the party
towards some values that need to be
inherent in the party and so we use that
structure to kind of talk about it
here's where we were in the past we
celebrate the working people as the hero
they're really the heroes of not just
our economy but the holy priests of well
frankly is the American worker and we've
sort of gotten away from that and gotten
too divisive and so the end is a big
message that's much more unifying yeah
and so for people who are watching you
can see in the actual structure of the
of the story you can see at some point
you know there's this kind of
celebration and then you see an actual
wave like you actually show this big
wave coming down and so this is this
this flood that comes in and for those
who've been watching my videos you know
I always talk about how that's how the
world is structured there's this flood
at the end of something and then there
has
your rebirth and then you have something
else and so then there you have this
flood and then there's this rebirth and
you can see you know this image of
people marching down the the road kind
of all together in unison and and one of
the things that I noticed which I which
I I'm happy about is that there is
obviously in the Democratic Party in
let's say on the left in general there
is this notion that it's important to
celebrate diversity if we kind of follow
Jordan's idea about you know what the
Liberals are and what the left you know
the left side is then it makes sense
that there's this vision that diversity
creates opportunities creates that
difference is something which helps us
to to find new opportunities and I think
that I think that what's interesting and
what I think is great is that this in
that story where you do show a lot of
diversity different types of people
different types of places in life you
also have things like you celebrate
fatherhood in this little clip or you
have a fatherless child
you also don't exclude let's say the
white man you know the white man is part
of it is part of the diversity is part
of the story and he's there in the in
the in the story and so I think that you
know when you see that I really at least
I felt like there really is this desire
to move away from seeing let's say
diversity as something which opposes
something which wants to take down the
system but rather seeing this coming
together under them under the banner
building of building a country and and
doing it together so so I thought it was
very I thought it was very successful in
doing that my my question i I have is
this is this has to do with this the
power of symbolism let's say is it seems
to me when I watch it that on the one
hand you're trying to communicate a
message of the party but you're also
trying to affect the party itself you're
also trying to message both to the
inside and to the outside of what's
possible like what story is possible to
tell so maybe you can tell us a little
bit about about that about what tack
that it's that's a very astute
observation me one of things Marshall
and I discussed a lot and also of Callie
was that in a lot of ways the
message is the substance do you wanna
mean like if you if we can put something
forth that people find compelling then
that can start to become the ways that
people discuss things and I think
there's a lot of ways than that have
Democrats March in the front door and
say I'm for universal health care as a
right and I'm for a woman's right to
choose and I'm for gun control
everybody's immediately in a rush like
once you start to use buzzwords and
ideology it's like everyone raise your
hand who's on one side of the issue or
another and there's much more
interesting and valid ways that we can
talk that's more authentic to what our
beliefs are to talk about specific
issues all everything is on the slippery
slope whether we talk about gun control
weather talk about immigration an
increasingly the parties have gone to a
point where the sentiment that is echoed
everyone's dug in their heels and it's
like all immigration is bad or all
immigration is good it's like neither of
those is correct or valid and so when
you're talking about how we message I'm
really glad you notice that sort of
celebration as of diversity is a
strength certainly but it's also within
a unifying message and for me you know
there's a section of the video where
we're a series of different people say I
don't care what God you pray to I don't
care what color your skin is I don't
care if you drive a tractor or in a
small business and sure enough some
people do both of those things you know
we just want to make sure everyone plays
by the same rules there has to be
unification even in our diversity and I
think where we really get off course is
is when we're driven to these extremes
you know by each end of the party and
then won't concede any ground and so
it's either that anyways yeah I've
showed you know I've done a video where
I kind of show the two opposites where I
kind of show these two extremes you know
you have Trump saying build a wall and
then we have Justin Trudeau saying
diversity is our strengths and it's like
those are really the two extremes it's
as if you you know if you build a wall
and you totally close yourself off you
asphyxiate but if you you just say
diversity of our is our strengths and
you don't have any appeal to unity then
that's decomposition you know it's like
yeah that's what your composing is when
it Elian AIT's a lot of the population
also
it's only about diversity if you get up
and rattle off every diverse group and
leave out white man like people are
gonna be aware of who is it named versus
you kind of say look where this is
something that we're all in together I
mean you know Jonathan hi you I'm sure
you've read his work as well I mean he
puts it so elegantly when he talks about
that the role of conservatives you know
is to be protective of an in-group in a
lot of ways and that's not some sort of
vile in state it's a it's very very
helpful to have some concern about you
know it's an evolutionarily selective
trait if you think about you know Native
Americans when Europeans came like maybe
it's a wise choice of moms to be wary of
out-group and infection and contagion
from out perhaps it certainly serves a
purpose but as you said if you build a
wall that is too impenetrable new ideas
and people won't get in and will
stagnate and die and any effective
society has to be in relation of those
two idea so we can't have that diversity
is our only strength and we also can't
have that we're building an airtight
wall in all cases we can't have no
immigration at all or all immigration be
good and so as long as we're entrenched
in that for the purposes of political
discussion or winning elections we can
actually get to real solutions that are
gonna matter
yeah and I think I think that I it's
funny because I read I was when I
watched the ad I was kind of looking
down to you know we always look in the
YouTube comments and I was reading the
YouTube comments obviously there was a
usual just kind of degraded comment but
some of the comments were interesting in
the sense that there were it's literally
you know some people saying I'm a
conservative I'm a Republican but if
this is the message that Democrats are
going to be using then I'm thankful for
that because now we can actually have a
discussion like now we can actually
engage in actual discussion and and
because if we know when we fall into
these polar opposites
then it's a war there's no other
solution like we're gonna fight you know
either
even if it's just with words but it's
going to be just this constant trying to
block the other person and trying to get
our people in and and then we're
actually not producing anything
productive we're only it's only becomes
a kind of tribal warfare which
go anywhere yeah and I think you know
you're right to make that point so a lot
of Republicans are like hey we hate
corruption too but guess what you want
to court me you go first
how are you gonna be not corrupt then if
you want me to cross it over and
consider your party your party's not
airtight you know and so we have to talk
a lot about what are the pledges we're
gonna make for young candidates to
either win back the trust the Democrats
who we lost or to start to have
conversations with centrists or
Republicans who might be open to that so
we got to clean up our side of the
street and I think the other thing
that's really important is there's this
view that progressives tend to take
sometimes as if all Republicans or
conservatives sort of lack empathy and
are delighted in people who can't make
their way on a dominance hierarchy and
it's like conservatives care a lot about
how we take care like there's a lot of
people who necessarily will be left out
of a dominance hierarchy I'll give you
one example 29% of people the United
States right now are valid who are
military age are valid to make it
through into the military and that and
it's either due to obesity or lack of
ability to read or write there's only 29
percent of ineligible people which means
that we're leaving out you know 71% of
people can't meet a basic standard
that's not good for any for any aspect
right there's people who are being sort
of left behind that has to do also with
protection drafting security of the
country and also stupid people who if
you can't get into the military it's not
like other options are piling up at
their door either conservatives don't
like that you can't take a position that
conservatives all all of them that the
only thing that they care about is sort
of making money and lacking empathy and
leaving people behind but as long as we
are pushing that like they're pushing
that all that Democrats who want to do
is create a welfare nation and give
money to undeserving people we can't
actually have conversations about what
the solutions are from both sides and
both perspectives and so there's a lot
of people who have a more conservative
inclination than I do who are very
concerned about people who are left out
of dominance hierarchies whether it's
with work or education or building a
family and we can't get to their
solutions in
ideas in good faith if we've decided
that all of them are morally
insignificant and we're spending our
time for two signaling about it so I'm
actually curious maybe a lot of the
concerns that Democrats put forth
because we tend to be oriented on the
working class and the underdog because
that's part of our proclivity work but
maybe there's a lot of solutions also
from conservatives and the water can
service you can find holes in what we're
doing in ways to better improve that'll
make them more effective and as long as
we're busy slinging mud at different
approaches and you know magically
mind-reading people's lack of virtue and
motives we can't actually get to those
conversations to say hey you and I
disagree on maybe some of these
approaches and policies but how do we
actually sit down and talk about how do
you want to fix this here's my proposal
what are all the things you think are
awful and lacking in my proposal like
let's have all those discussions
yeah and I think I think there's also
just a what ends up happening and we see
it is that people they just stop
recognizing each other they don't they
just don't recognize each other so you
know I'm not right now I'm in South
Carolina so I'm in the south I guess and
you know I meet people who are
Republicans who are really super
conservative you know and there are some
of the most generous you know just open
and and and inviting and welcoming
people that I've ever met and and so
when when you if you give this image of
just a good old boy who you know is a
racist or whatever then how the people
that that that are Republican and aren't
like that they just they just say well
you're not [ __ ] about me
I don't know who you're talking about
you're talking about some people you're
talking about something it's not me so
I'm not I'm gonna stop I'm gonna stop
listening to you now because you say
you're talking about me but you're not
and so a Jordan sorry it's what people
do to Jordan right yeah that's right
like here's a straw man that's my
version of everything that you think who
I ran out demolish yeah that's nice but
you talking about to me yeah but it was
it was interesting because there's
actually my relationship with Jordan
which kind of awakened me to this
problem because I mean I've been
somewhat aware of this of this kind of
problem of misrepresentation but then I
got to know Jordan and we kind of became
friends and then you just hit this whole
scandal and I was watching the news and
I was listening to the CBC and I was
reading online I thought who are they
talking about I don't even know who
they're talking abouts all of a sudden I
realized just how distorted our
narratives have become and how there
really is this need to kind of refocus
and to find places where we can discuss
and I and I and I do appreciate this
kind of intellectual dark web group you
know even though I don't know how long
it's going to actually last but you know
I think that for now it's good to that
you can have someone like you know bench
up here talking to sam harris which just
seems like an impossible thing to happen
there but you're watching it happen and
you're watching an actual civil
discussion between you know two very
strong opposites but that are willing to
engage honestly with the other person so
that's what that's definitely what we're
we're all hoping for at least that's
what I want yeah all right so I want to
I want to move then to your to your
storytelling you know you mentioned in
just when we talked about the ad and you
talked about how yeah the the epic of
gilgamesh is the same story is
terminator maybe you could go into that
a little bit because I think I see a lot
of relationship with your own structure
that you use in your own story so maybe
go into that a bit and I'll have some
questions about what I read of you of
you until now well so here's what's a
little tricky it's like in your work
you're playing so beautifully with
archetypes and icons and symbols
that's overtly what you're doing you
know and with writing what's very
interesting is I have a story structure
kind of embedded in my head everybody
like yeah I'm in LA so one of my jokes
is you need tons of people who want to
be writers and very few who actually
want to write yeah and you know so a lot
of people say oh I took this course on
right on we're on writing the novel I
took the screenwriting class I read this
book and part of it is like if you love
books read a thousand books you know if
you love screenplays watch a thousand
movies so that there becomes this sort
of internal awareness of how things
structure I also you know Jordan was my
professor I did a you know I did
personality psych I did a young seminar
with him he was my thesis advisor I did
for Dean and onion analysis of
Shakespearean they're a now you know my
contention is Shakespeare was a great
thriller writer if you get to the trap
in that he was you know highly
convention bound highly structured tales
of lust intrigue and murder designed to
appeal the broadest possible
cross-section society and he was
interested in putting butts and chairs
and selling out the globe theater you
know he was he was also commercial and
so so I have a really strong grasp of
the hero's journey but if I sit down to
write a book that is and it's one of my
criticisms people who take too many
courses and when you take a lot of
classes read a lot of books what they
tend to teach is structure because
structure can be taught what can't be
taught is dialogue because it's
different every single time out and
those character moments that really make
you engage with somebody that's really
your ability to see the world as an
artist and figure out what are those
little tells of character that make you
fall in love with somebody so
structurally it's very important to have
that understanding and then you sort of
forget it almost and then to embark on a
very specific from the ground up level
of here's a guy who's doing the thing in
a situation that's a moral dilemma you
know so then you start to build it that
way so I always have this sort of
lingering notions of what the hero's
myth is books well you know thrillers
will always have a structure that you
know you're starting out there's a Miss
you're intrigued at some point in the
middle there's a big dip like you talked
about that you shaped story structure
and then the end there's something
emergent that creates order out of chaos
like the post-flood right and so I'm
very aware of that and I will play with
imagery that's even over sometimes like
during that descent I will sometimes
play around with you know underworld
imagery like it's The Odyssey or The
Iliad right but it's very important to
also make things very very specific to
character and because people don't want
to just read a flash tower's archetypal
you know and you can see the lock with
kind of cop movies and genre things that
get buried by the numbers and they'll
still function well even though they're
by the numbers I mean so we all know the
story right it's like the cop and he's
on a stakeout with his young friend and
the you know his young partner who gets
shot and then it's personal or the cop
whose wife and kids get killed and then
it's personal there's certain structures
that are so clear
seeing that even if the execution is
middling it's sort of pinging that
little pleasure center in our brain for
revenge or order or you know masculine
strength but you don't want to resort to
that to fully and things that are better
take those archetypes and sort of
transcend them and making them more
specific and personal yeah I think I
think that the way that like the way
that I talk about it in my videos and
the way my brother talks about it is
book is really this idea you could call
it like a meeting of Heaven and Earth
where you you have a pure pattern like a
pure spiritual essence or however you
want to call it and then you have the
world of particularity and they have to
join together like they have to meet
together and you can't you can't if you
sacrifice one for the other then you
have you end up with something which is
lacking which either which either lacks
the the capacity to create empathy that
you talked about if it's too abstract
and it's too it's too much of it just a
pattern or else it lacks the the
capacity to make you kind of to give you
a vision of the world which is what the
pattern is able to do is able to to kind
of make you feel like this is meaningful
like it's not just a bunch of things
that happen to someone like there's this
even though you can have a really
amazing character it's like I mean some
people like reading Proust I can't read
Proust you know like there's there's
some types of literature that we've seen
that that will never appeal to a large
audience because it's not showing them
giving them this sense of meaning in
their in their life so I feel like
proves I didn't know when to knock him
if you like it yeah for me it's Derek
dawn Foucault who I just fine deadening
we dull okay but you know what's
interesting is when you're writing a lot
of the same rules apply you know when
you're looking back you can see
structure in areas of interest that you
don't know if you're just pursuing
things that are interests right yeah so
I started to pursue kind of trying to
talk out of the civic responsibility of
trying to fix the things in my own party
that I felt needed to be fixed
that was really my starting point
because you know I don't want to just
assign blame in a way that is peripheral
for the state of polarized discourse I
want to really look at it and see where
I can change it but what's very
interesting is I started to dive into
this is that the same rules apply for
writing as do for politics so guess what
you don't
want to do is you don't want to write in
cliches right you don't want to write
characters who were a straw man you
don't want your antagonist to have a
very easily knocked down able worldview
I mean the bad guy never then she's the
bad guy you want them to have an
ingrained and rich philosophy and if you
start to write in a whole series of
cliches that people have seen in her
before then your writings weak you
haven't hit that specificity so guess
what is you import that into politics
you know it's the same thing as people
start to say if you can walk into a room
and say you know government keep the
government out of my uterus it's
immediately a sentiment that's gonna
divide everybody you know what they
think already versus having a
conversation about you know women's
desire to maintain control over their
own bodies in a way that's that's more
sophisticated and that is engaged with
some understanding of how could not
everybody should just agree with that
right away or else they're
mouth-breathing troglodytes
and it's likewise from the other side
you know like you know they can take my
gun when they pry my you know cold dead
fingers from my gun doesn't leave a lot
of room for for you know subtlety or
discussions to talk about where we are
and what things in society including gun
owners want to have to make to show more
gun discipline or to have things be safe
while also respecting the Second
Amendment so these sort of cliched
phrases when you do them in books it
means you're not a strong writer and
when they're trotted out in politics it
has the effect of just shutting down the
other side completely if you're using
buzzwords if you're using ideological
phrases I mean one of the jokes I may
turn up in America under Reagan and
being from a you know more liberal
family that voted Democrat for Avril
Family Values was a phrase that was used
so much here to mean a particular thing
that I always say it wasn't till I was
grown up and married and had a kid and
had two kids that I was like wait a
minute
I like family values like family values
are good I should have some fan because
it was used as such a political Kajal
cuz I'm here you weren't there actually
hearing what they were saying you were
just saying here's my enemy saying
something and and if he keeps saying it
for some reason and he's he's he's uh
let's say he's uh he's
coding like he's he's saying this coded
language that is going to to reach the
people that he wants to reach but it
didn't have any any actual content well
I have a theory to that as as ideology
becomes ossified into buzz words and
phrases from either side this is not me
picking on Republicans or Family Values
because I think this is equivalent as
things get get condensed into buzz words
that are news bites they lose
authenticity and are much more often
used for manipulative a fact yeah you
know and so that's part of what the
reaction we have to sort of cliches and
buzzwords just like people have real
sentiments they figure out how to boil
it down into something that's a neat
catchy slogan then it gets used it used
and use the news that anyone as opposed
to it recognizes it as a sort of empty
slogan it's an ideological manipulation
in some ways like when people talked
about Family Values forever or when
people talked about you know the things
from from Democrats also that are that
are the phrase words you know it starts
to become detached from the actual
meaning and human experience of it and
obviously it's a necessity to
communicate in the market for
politicians on both sides right it's a
rallying cry to say keep the government
out of my uterus but that's not gonna be
a starting point to engage with somebody
who is you know a pro-life born-again
Christian who has a lot of deeply felt
emotional feelings about about abortion
it's honest it's not a starting point
it's sort of a shutdown point yeah and
you know I'm vehement ly pro-choice but
I think that it needs that this needs to
be conversation that's engaged with with
great respect yeah
but I think that I think that's one of
them at least a discussion I don't see
the discussion the discussion happening
I think that especially that question is
a very is very difficult because I you
you do have you're not two sides of this
are not talking to each other in just
got you guys you have one side saying a
choice and the other person saying life
really I mean you you have the two sides
so it's like one president saying how
can you not care that that you're
destroying a human life the other person
can't see it doesn't see that and saying
how do can you not
they're that you're intruding into my
personal responsibilities in my personal
choices so that discussion is I don't
see that discussion happening anywhere
you know sadly so I don't know I don't
know where it's gonna go I did but but I
think that hopefully we can at least
find some places where where where we
can discuss well here's the thing I
there are certain issues we're gonna
disagree about fundamentally another job
of humans the job of humans is to have
different perspectives whether you're
libertarian democrat or republican we're
for me it starts to get problematic is
when either side like the issue you just
said that's not fixable that's not like
we can all just sit down and solve this
but where it gets really problematic and
gets worse is when either side starts to
impugn the motives of the other side
yeah now I agree I think I always tell
people exactly that I say you know when
when you know when exactly like for
example when even on the let's say on
the Pro on the pro-choice side when
someone says your purpose like you're
you the reason why you're doing what
you're doing is because you want to
control women and it's like the people
who are on the products I can't hear
that argument because they're saying no
saying the reason why we say that is
because we think it's a human life and
you can't destroy human life and then
the people on the human life side are
saying you know you're killing babies
you know you don't care about killing
babies and they're saying that's not
what we're talking about we're saying no
this is about it so they're just not
they're not talking to each other if
that is actually an issue that's
definitely an issue where you can see
that the two sides are just completely
not they're just not not communicating
it's also you know it's also part of it
of like tell me your position and I'll
tell you your moral failing yeah yeah
you know and it's like sometimes it's
not sometimes someone just believes
something different and that's okay and
it has to be discussed in ways that are
not saying that they are monstrous or
morally lacking and yeah well you don't
because they they yeah or that you don't
immediately demonize someone because
they have a different opinion than you
then the discussion isn't totally
impossible
impossible to even even have it that's
for sure well I'm from a negotiating
perspective it becomes impossible to
figure out something that might actually
function yeah you know Mike I see this
so clearly with the gun control gun
discipline problem is if somebody walks
in immediately it says you know I'm for
gun control you can have any
conversation to talk about the fact that
we have you know a lot of gun owners
there's so much agreement about specific
things like you know violent violent
history checks right there's certain
things where you know 90% of Americans
and 73% of NRA members are in favor of
violent history checks it's actually not
that controversial and so but if you
want to get any very specific things
that we might say hey maybe this is
something that we should look at that
can we look at this one thing versus
coming in in a largely abstract way and
not getting to the specific everyone's
gonna just tell further toward their
extreme because it's like if you're
coming in telling me you want to abolish
the Second Amendment and take my guns
away everyone who owns guns is is
violent and stupid like why would you
listen to anything anyone has to say you
can't have a negotiation or series of
compromises when you don't believe that
the a the other side is engaging in good
faith and B that there are no
circumstances under which they will be
satisfied and I see that as the big fear
when we're discussing certain what I
think are reasonable parameters with
with the Second Amendment to say let's
just look at violent history checks the
fear from the other side is you're not
gonna be happy with that
I'm gonna give that up to you and then
you're gonna do what's next and you're
gonna do what's after that you're gonna
what's after that until you get rid of
the Second Amendment because that's your
secret motive yeah yeah yeah that's
definitely that's definitely what I see
from the conservative side is that that
the that the progressive agenda is
exactly that it's a progressive agenda
and so it's it's seen as you know one
thing you do another you do another you
do another and then it's not clear
exactly where it's not always clear
exactly where we're going but it seems
like there's some setup steps like in
the in the process and we're you know
we're gonna go on these steps no matter
what so so yeah that that definitely
that's definitely the perception that I
see from the
the conservative side it's definite to
hear the other way to to be fair is like
you know there's when conservatives are
giving voice to you know due process of
a lot like that you can't blindly
believe every accuser whether male and
female everything there is a concern
from the left that is like that series
of choices is gonna be wielded
fraudulently and corruptly to denigrate
the rights of people who are less
empowered and it's going to lead to a
Handmaid's Tale right so it that concern
exists on both sides and people are dug
in I mean it is not that big of a
stretch if you think about you know
we're current fights and intimate
relationships
you can't wind up in your marriage or in
your relationship not ceding any ground
I mean those are those are the marriages
that end in divorce where you don't
believe in any good-faith concession you
can make where every little choice in
your life in your marriage in your house
is a battleground yeah you can't get
anywhere with that yeah yeah you have to
engage in good faith and see someone
else's perspective and also be aware to
look at your blind spots like when
people talk about perspective in a
marriage right though you have a partner
who brings you greater perspective
that's actually literal there's somebody
outside of you looking at you who can
see your blind spots in a way that you
can't and if you want to turn everything
into a battleground that your
perspective is what wins all the time
marriage ain't gonna work and in America
we're dead split I mean you look at the
last few elections it's we're not having
races that are going 70/30 but we're
married so so we can either cross our
arms and digging our heels or we can try
to figure out ways they kind of can come
together and there's extremes in both
sides of the party that are not gonna be
gained for this and don't probably
deserve much of our attention but
there's a huge SWAT the vast majority of
people on both sides of the political
divide we got to figure out how to live
together ya know I think that that's
definitely that's definitely the that's
definitely the the hope is that people
will at least learn to to talk to each
other but and I think that this that a
lot of these these conversations that
are happening online are giving us a
little bit of of a hope that it's
possible it leads to have these
discussions
and I and I think that you know those
people that are willing like you and I
now are like I'm obviously okay I was
telling you on the phone the other day
like I'm an icon Carver you know it
there's probably very few ways I don't
even have to signal how conservative I
am like in terms of just like that I
just my title makes me makes it pretty
obvious but I think that like like you
said I think it's really important to to
engage and to talk and to kind of get a
sense of what people are how people are
perceiving you as well and and to
understand that yeah you know in
fairness I did like your series of icon
carvings of transgender bathrooms though
I thought that was pretty clear yeah
those right there yeah those are I did
they're not under a pseudonym they're
they're not swear now yeah I mean it is
funny when you come from different from
different sides of trying to figure out
you know how we still engage look I want
to talk a little bit about Batman cuz
yeah let's talk about them and III that
that's something that I'm really I mean
I read so I read I read the volume 2 of
your your your Batman stories and I
don't know if you saw the video that I
did on Batman and Adam and Eve so I'd
like to get your take on on Batman
because that's a wide character but
there there's definitely there's that
you know that he definitely had a
particular take on him so maybe go ahead
and tell me about Batman well so first
of all I was totally delighted when I
got the chance to write Batman for DC as
you can imagine as well I got the call
and had to act super cool and
professional and my inner like geek boy
12 year old was like doing cartwheels
down the hall what I found when I was
getting in and writing Batman that I was
very interested in is the dynamic and I
used this to some extent an orphan acts
because it was sort of a so the dynamic
particularly in men between perfection
and intimacy that was something that I
found so it's like hearing a Batman who
can't fly he doesn't have a magic ring
like Green Lantern there's that many
superpowers but he represents the
pinnacle of human discipline
right and part of why you can do that is
he's an only child his parents were
killed when he was young right Robin's
always dying like we get a new Robin and
Robin dies he dates women under his
pseudonym and they either die or they
vanish or it's unattainable sort of
temptresses like Catwoman right there's
a big divide between the people he dates
or is the female characters he's engaged
with as Batman versus as Bruce Wayne and
one of the things that was interesting
to me was that he can be as close to
perfect as a human can gasps without
magic skills but with sheer discipline
and sheer willpower in part because he
has no intimacy but once you have
intimacy it's a recognition of the
limitations of the world right I always
think of it like when I had kids the way
I thought about was that my the surface
area of my vulnerability increased right
and you can't protect it all like once
you're intimate and you don't want your
kid to go to school and get bullied
right you don't want once you're married
you don't you know you're open if you're
if your spouse has health issues like
there's just it's a bigger range of
things they start to you know fear and
that's even literally down to a level of
your schedule like I used to just get up
go to the computer write all that like
there's no interruptions but if you want
to have a wife and dogs and kids and you
know a lot of friends in your life
things are gonna get interrupted you
have to you have to widen out more into
fullness with intimacy and perfection
and somebody's take some laser focus
so it's very interested in that and I
imported that in ways I'm sure you were
aware of when I started to write orphan
acts that's the struggle there's like
here's this guy this kid who was pulled
up in a foster home at the age of 12
we're used to be an assassin but his
moral compass was never broken like his
mentor and father figure tells him the
hard part won't be making you a killer
the hard part is keeping you human and
so he's torn in conflict between those
two of being like the perfect trained
assassin but also having the moral
compass that's unbroken wanted to hang
on there was humanity yeah
well it's interesting because you know
you you brought up the the structure of
terminator before and and I think that
that those two opposites in Terminator
are definitely at least in the first one
they're shown as almost unreachable
opposite so you have
perfect world Skynet you know this kind
of technological perfection and then you
have this woman you know who's kind of
messed up and kind of you know just just
kind of chaotic and so one is basically
trying to kill the other and the other
person just has to defend themselves you
know until the end from this this this
this intrusion and so it seems like
there's something very interesting in in
this idea of the humanizing capacity
right of this feminine character that
you in orphan X at least that's kind of
how you set it up is you had this this
uh this the single mother right with her
with her their child and and in coming
into contact with this character
suddenly the the the assassin starts to
find himself compromising some making
thing deciding things he wouldn't decide
and and slipping and then finally kind
of entering into an actual relationship
with with that family not just what the
woman do with the child and so there's
something and so there's something about
that that let's say at least that strong
opposite at the beginning I don't know
how you you cuz you mentioned also
Gilgamesh you have that in yoga match to
it's a bit different but you do have
this idea of this it's it's kind of
almost the opposite of that where you
have a wild character
Anke knew who's in the forest and is
completely wild and then this female
character comes and humanizes him by
entering into her entering into
relationship with him it seems like in
your story and in Terminator 2 you have
the the flip side where it's this it's
the city character like that it's almost
as if it's it's a its Gilgamesh himself
who would have been tamed by the this
this woman character but maybe Gilgamesh
is actually tamed by Enkidu himself like
he's actually those true together like
this kind of wild very particular very
connected to nature character and this
this this this almost tyrannical figure
when they meet together then they have
in a way they they they balance each
other out like one of them becomes more
human and the other one also takes on
some meaning so I really saw that I saw
that not only in your own four necks and
in Batman but even in some of the other
tropes that were being played out in
your volume too because there's also in
an impact in his in the Greg's volume to
eat it's with scarecrow and so scarecrow
is also this like he's
he he almost has like this story with
his father where this this crazy
professional who who is so bent on
discovering what fear is that he has no
humanity left in him and then scarecrow
encounters this one of his victims who
remains human despite everything he does
to him and finally there's this little
moment that the in the story where he
actually helps her you know like this
surprise moment were actually helped her
and then you see that you know that
there's this possibility of change in a
person anyway so maybe you can talk a
bit about a bit more that's how I I was
seeing it especially as you had
mentioned terminator before so maybe you
can tell me a bit about how you see you
mentioned this story a few times to me
about this this Terminator story so I
don't know how you see it connected well
yeah it's interesting your observations
around that are interesting I mean the
thing is the Terminator especially when
you get to the sequel yeah you really
see that it's it's basically the taming
of a wild beast great right and it's but
I love the way James Cameron writes
female characters I just think he's
amazing
and if you look at Linda Hamilton she's
so tough and so badass and she's so
empowered but she's also source like
she's also deeply feminine at the same
time right so it's not just that it's an
overlay of her into a male character
that you just switched the the
anatomical parts yeah and keep in mind I
mean she's pregnant at the end of
terminator right and she's a protective
there's a protective mother aspects what
I love so much in you know aliens is
like when Sigourney Weaver finally gets
pissed off it's like it's the Mama
Grizzly when you've got between her in
our cause and so there's a different
sort of texture to to what that is and
how and how it functions and I think
Cameron does not beautifully where he
doesn't write paper-thin female
characters he writes them with a lot of
death and you know just because you're
writing strong women doesn't mean that
you're writing them complicatedly like
we don't talk about people writing
strong man right I mean you want complex
man care male characters right it's like
strong is still one dimension if you
don't bottom it out in ways whether
that's for male characters and female
characters so Terminator is always very
interesting for me in that way to have a
female protagonist
who uses a lot of feminine power to
affect the plot but it is interesting
like so within Batman I was pretty well
known for recreating the villains I
think would speak to my own darker
proclivities so my first assignment
there was I kind of they were doing the
new 52 which was a recreation and a
recreation of the universe and I started
with the penguin DC kind of said you can
do anything that you want when they were
kind of stealing me from from Marvel
they said you can have any character who
you want and do whatever you want I said
I want to write a mini-series on the
penguin and he looked at me like are you
insane you could have you know flash or
Superman you wanna do mini-series on the
penguin who's like the biggest joke
character yeah and it was so funny
because I so admire Alan Moore's The
Killing Joke about the Joker which we
can talk about Miss AK because that I
kind of didn't amage to that in the
later thing and so I still remember we
announced it but I was like I see this
in a particular way and I want to write
it and we announced it and I remember
there was an Internet poll of a most
eagerly anticipated series coming up and
it listed six of them and my penguin
miniseries got point oh one two percent
of the vote in my favorite all-time
anonymous internet comment somebody said
I'm really glad her which is mom voted
for him like nobody cared but the thing
is it was a real lesson because I wrote
it the critics came the fans came and
that's what I kind of parlayed into
Batman because I just had a sense of how
wants to do it and what I wanted to do
is if you're the penguin if you're short
and stout and unattractive Batman's a
bully like if you really switch the lens
the perspective like penguins this guy
who's like trying to make do he's always
been unattractive he's always been fat
he's always on the bad end of it and as
much as his moral compass is completely
off-kilter here's this tall like you
know cleft chin superhero who swings in
and beats him up again and again yeah I
just thought what a cool trope to turn
that on a tad and to give the penguin a
very real perspective and depth and a
bit of humanity which you talked about
with my scarecrow story also that we're
getting inside
in a way that's real he's not just sort
of a cackling you know malcontents but
actually has you know felt emotions and
feelings and his beat up and so I try
and always look at these things from the
perspective of the opposing side because
people think that like if you major
during tagging is really really bad you
know that'll make your hero even
stronger and it's like it's not the case
know if your antagonist is complex and
has a worldview that we can almost
relate to yeah but our protagonist can
engage with that ambiguity and chaos and
still come out and emerge and win the
day that actually occurs more positively
to the protagonist oh yeah you can see
you've got a good example that happened
just in the last few years is the
difference between the Justice League
movie and the last Avengers movie it's
like the bad guy in the Justice League
movie is just the who he knows what his
motivations are just this evil barely
exists he's just like an abstract evil
person and and Santos in the vendor's
movie was at least given it was fleshed
out and you can and there's some strange
moments where you can almost understand
like why he's doing what he's doing and
then you pull back and you say no no
this is this is scary you know so so I I
definitely agree that that's something
so so the idea is that penguin is
basically he sees themselves kinda like
as a victim of Batman like he's that bad
as you know that's the most dangerous
position oh yeah yeah believes they're
murdered at the hands of someone else
like virtually every genocide has been
perpetrated on behalf of people who
believe that who they are exterminating
has victimized that that's right
so there's another aspect I wanted to
talk about a little bit in my Batman I
wrote a a Batman Dark Knight a zero
edition that sort of an origin story
yeah that I haven't really discussed
that much but one of the things it deals
it's very archetypal so I wanted to talk
about it with you a little bit I don't
know if you've read that why I did I did
I did I cuz that's why I cuz it kind of
came with volume two like I bought well
into and then I read it and then you're
at the end so I did read it I thought
thought is really interesting maybe go
ahead and tell me what you kind of what
you were thinking and I'll give you my
impression of it well I so I was trying
to retell like zero the zero editions
they Marvel or DC did this thing where
we have we wrote you know issued on
it was supposed to be an orange until so
I wanted to write about Joe Chill who's
the guy who killed Bruce's parents right
in the alleyway and the conventional
story is he was just some thug who shot
them and he wanted the pearl necklace
okay so I told it in very surreal
fashion and I picked it up with young
Bruce who's trying to find meaning in
this he goes off to high school and he's
drawing charts and maps of like who
really killed my parents who's behind it
was that this corrupt person was that
this crime family was it this person
who's opposed to my dad's charity was at
this business rival he's trying to shape
order out of this and it's you know from
being a little kid all the way forward
through the president through schooling
I really trace and show the strength of
this desire to get to the bottom of it
and when he's in school his teacher when
he's in high school
interspersed with this is sort of
talking about I think you know quoting
Emerson and Emerson talked about if you
look in your heart you will see some
internal design that matches a map of
nature and it is beautiful right and
that the individualism he's sort of a
defining father in some ways or of
American individualism you know to know
what is true in your own heart that is
true for all mankind that is genius and
imitation is suicide
yeah so it's just beautiful in her order
and so that's what burst is being taught
when he's in school so he finally gets
aleck fault tracks down different clues
and gets to see Joe Chill and when he
kicks in the door he's gonna kill him
and this is before he's Batman right
he's a young man now and Joe Chill is in
this miserable apartment he's unshaven
there's booze and pizza wrappers he
slumped in the corner all kind of drunk
drugged out and in his window that's
propped open
it's a rickety sash window there's a
volume of Edgar Allan Poe and whenever
Allan Poe sad is the exact opposite he
was the perfect inversion of Emerson
which is if you look in your heart what
you will see is utter chaos and what you
will see is the pointlessness and
nihilism of the world that is so
terrifying that you'll be drawn to it in
a way that that you seek to destroy
herself and that's Joe Joe Kelly and
when Bruce goes in
what he realizes is all of his desire to
give shape right to have meaning behind
his father's death is nonsense he was
just this drunk guy who wanted the
pearls and there isn't any comforting
conspiracy to be had yeah and he doesn't
kill him because you can't kill chaos
when he goes outside and he's very
emotional and he's walking and there's
ads for the circus right the circus that
Robin was raised in on the wall and one
of them's a smiling clown and Batman not
Batman Bruce Wayne leaves against Ted it
starts to rain on him and he's
recovering his breath and as he's
leaning against it the rain streets the
poster and pulls the happy clown figure
into a scowl in the Derby eyes that
prefigures the Joker though the Joker
doesn't yet exist burse isn't yet Batman
the Joker isn't yet the Joker but what I
wanted to show was that shattering of
comforting conspiracy and meaning into
the chaos of the world is gonna be his
lifelong struggle he's trying to find
order and the Joker represents of course
chaos yeah just wants to see the world
burn yeah I thought I thought that it
was a really I was really thought that
it was a very effective way to tell this
story and also because like you said I
think that when you said he can't kill
chaos was a was a perfect way to to
phrase it is that he you know if it had
been some conspiracy theory all he would
have had to do is to find you know like
to go up the conspiracy find the source
of the conspiracy knock that off and
then he's done right he's done he's
finished she's finished his mission but
what he ends up being is it's a much
bigger mission that he gives himself
which is that it's a faceless right it's
a faceless chaos that he's trying to
keep back it's like it's not Joe Chill
it's it's it's every thug it's every
every criminal it's every it's every
possible way that someone can how chaos
can kind of seep in and so he's this
gargoyle you know standing on the
building and he's one of the he's a
guardian of the city he's holding back
this this dark chaos that's on the
outside so I thought that I thought that
it was a really good it was a really
good way to to see it and then you know
the meaning that he
fines is not out it ends up not being
out there it ends up not being this
conspiracy that he's trying to find out
in the world but it ends up being he has
to internalize it right he has to she
has to be the one the meaning has to
come from him he has to be the one
standing on that border and kind of
holding the line of this kind of dark
chaos and so I really yeah I thought it
was a very effective way to tell to tell
that story you know and to to kind of
imagine really in a mythological way
like what that encounter with Joe Chill
is supposed to be you know what what is
this meaningless Killoren and and I
think that a lot of comics they've kind
of gone away from that it's in sometimes
like I think spider-man there they tried
to give some kind of like secret meaning
to why you know his uncle got killed and
they tried to find some weird trope
where they're trying to to make it a
bigger story but no the whole point of
these the story is that it's just this
meaningless thing that happens and it's
in trying to give it meaning but from
the inside that you that you can that
you get confronted so no I really did
appreciate it I would suggest people
should should look it up you can find it
it's easy to buy on comiXology or
something you can you can buy it well
that of course - as you as you well know
I mean in some ways that's the story of
Christ right you shoulder your own cross
right you accept your own suffering and
in doing so you can transcend that yeah
and so the gargoyle metaphor is so
interesting because it's so obvious and
I've never thought about it till you do
it which I'm embarrassed to admit so
don't tell anyone else exactly but I
mean Batman is constantly portrayed as a
gargoyle right I mean my covers have him
crouching on the roof of a building
right it's a constant guard girl image
reeks of course don't girls or to ward
off the spirits to protect the people in
the bases and or in the in in the
buildings well the truck tonight or it's
like it's so ingrained in us I didn't
even think about it consciously right
well the throat that I've been using is
really this image of of the you would I
call the garments of skin or the idea of
using chaos to fight chaos so using
darkness to fight darkness and so this
idea that Batman take you know just like
the
there really is this idea that you know
that you have these monsters that
protect you from bigger monsters right
so you have these small monsters on the
edge of the world and and they're kind
of dangerous they're kind of scary but
their actual function is to protect you
from way bigger monsters that are out
there and so Batman takes that like he
turns fear against itself he turns
darkness against itself it's like a
vaccine this idea of using the disease
to to cure a disease and and that seems
to be a really and that's that's why
he's so attractive to us because we can
really we recognize the pattern and we
can see and it's so funny like in the
little video that I made I I tried to
show how a lot of the elements of Batman
which don't seem to fit together
once you see it through that frame all
of a sudden you realize that they do
because the the idea of the garments of
skin is also related to the idea of our
animal self like our animal reality like
our bodily existence and and everything
that's flesh about us in the Bible it's
really at these garments of dead animal
skins that are put around it and then I
I just basically say Batman duck what he
does he dresses himself as a beast like
he actually you know you can imagine
those warriors that would put on wolf
heads and and as these animals and then
they would fight against the against the
enemy wearing those kinds of tropes or
Hercules wearing Alliance a Lions skin
right they embody that that kind of
chaotic passion but to do it you know to
stop your your thought the enemy from
from from coming in and so Batman
definitely seems to to embody that one
of the things that someone mentioned
recently in a conversation a private
conversation I had with someone who's a
very powerful conversation I had with
someone his name is Jason and he's very
ill he's he has a breathing mechanism
and he and he and he wanted to talk me
about Batman and Joker and and his take
on the Batman and Joker was quite
powerful I'd like to run it by you for
you to tell me what you think he really
saw it as two reactions to suffering
like he saw as if there's some scandal
in Joker's life something happened to
him you know that that broke him and
Batman also had that in his life he has
some thing that happened to him that
that that could have broken him
but they both reacted in two different
ways where one used it as fuel to to
basically defend you know the city and
the other one gave in to the nihilism
and into resentment and then just wants
to all help to break loose and I thought
and I thought even in Jordan in the
terms of how Jordan Peterson talks about
the world I thought it was a just I
never thought I had never thought about
that and I thought well that's a
fascinating idea and I saw the same in
your in your in your story with
scarecrow
there was something of that in there
which is like there's fear this
confrontation with fear and scarecrow
kinda gives in to fear whereas whereas
Batman says now I'm gonna turn fear
against itself like I'm going to to to
use fear to stop those that want to
bring fear to to the to the innocent
yeah I think that split is the split
between positive masculinity and
negative Master hmm right I mean and
that's something that you know one of
the I wrote a piece on positive
masculinity when I was on book tour New
England saying we talk all the time
about toxic masculinity but we're never
talking about positive masculinity and
like what that entails and some extent
that's sort of like being you know if
you're a Democrat you're only talking
about you know making the rules fair for
everybody but you're not talking about
the aspirational people that have
anything tuned for right so it's a very
similar thing and I do see that split
that way I play with it a lot in orphan
acts also that notion that like to catch
a monster you have to become a monster
yeah right and so a big aspect of that
and we see again and again within with
Batman too is like you have to walk that
kind of sine-wave between the yin and
yang you have to have one foot those are
the two eyeballs right in chaos in an
order and you have to be good enough
that as you're walking that razor blade
edge as a monster is fighting monsters
that you don't tell it in the total
chaos
yeah and that'sthat's the strength of
the adventuring archetypal hero
yeah yeah and you see you know and you
kind of see it paired up like in stories
especially in Batman and Joker like you
they end up pairing them up like they
almost become they almost become like
these metaphysical opposites where you
have these two sides you know the eagle
and the snake or whatever these two
these two sides that are almost
self-defining like defining each other
and you know and even in the story trope
sometimes it's played out where you know
the one is even the cause of the other
so the enemy is is the one who cause the
good guy or sometimes it's the opposite
it's the hero who is the secret cause of
the enemy he did something and and you
see that in them in some of the Batman
stories it you get that where you know
it was Batman who was there and when the
Joker fell and fell in the in the acid
or something like he was somehow
involved in it and so you had this idea
that one causes the other the other
causes the one this this kind of eternal
conflict let's say of the two sides yeah
and it's you know look that's that's how
it functions I built a lot of that in
orphan acts also and what's so great
with Batman's Batman has the best rogues
gallery and it's because every single
one of those represents his opposite
every single person in his main rogues
gallery is a reflection of some aspect
of him yeah but God I'm wrong in a
different way and it's what's so
fascinating there's this 360 degree
circle around him of all villains who
represent some part of him yeah yeah
that day that's definitely in that
that's I mean yeah that's why he's so he
survives for so long and he's and
obviously he's not going away for a
while hopefully they'll get the movies
right though cuz this that's in a scary
spot right now no well
listen I think I think we've gone quite
a while I really appreciate I really
appreciate talking to you I I'll
definitely probably I have I read only
the first order for next book but I will
probably read the second one and start
to think about some of the things we've
talked about and see if I can if I can
see some of those patterns in there and
probably look into some of the other
comics that you're doing are you still
doing comics or is that finished now I'm
thinking about embarking
again after Batman it was such a great
experience I didn't think anything could
equal it but I'm sort of flirting with a
couple things now all right yeah all
right
well look it's so great great to talk to
you yeah it was good to meet you and and
yeah so I I will I will have put in the
the ad for the the Democratic the
Democratic guy did you put in two people
in the comments try to look at it try to
look at it objectively look at the
structure look at what's being said and
it would be great to see your comments
about it below and to so that we can get
the discussion going an actual real
discussion between the different sides
going so thanks everybody
thank you if you enjoyed this content
and our exploration of symbolism get
involved I love to read your insights
and questions in the comments section
you can also share this video on social
media to your friends and as you can
please consider supporting us
financially through patreon or PayPal
you'll find those links in the
description below